it's week 14 we're nearing the stretch
run here it's usually that time of year
where
you look at teams to make major moves
maybe it's a head coach maybe it's a gm
but we look at the eagles because it's
the face of their franchise carson wench
he gets benched
for this upcoming game against the
saints he was benched during
last weekend so now jalen hurts is in
tony i'm going to start with you what do
you think of the move
in the immediate and what do you think
of it long term
well i think it's it really ties into
both uh when i was an assistant coach
with the vikings in 1992 dennis green
told me something i never forgot he said
if you ever take your starting
quarterback out
know that it's permanent uh you can say
hey we're only taking him out for this
quarter
or he got banged up or or we're trying
to give the team a spark
but you've sent your team a message that
for some reason whatever it is
i don't believe in my quarterback
anymore i think jalen hurts gives us
more of a chance to win
this next game that's not a good message
to send unless you absolutely believe
that and so i think this is a watershed
moment from philadelphia
yeah and if you're doug peterson you
don't want to lose your locker room so
players expect their coach
to hold everyone accountable in that
locker room regardless of how much money
you make
and let's face it jalen hurts he's done
everything right
he works hard he's a good kid he
prepares
and he's ready for this opportunity and
carson wentz has been flat out terrible
so i say give give him the opportunity
not just as a rpo guy not just as an
option quarterback let him drop back
put him in there for four quarters of
course he's going to face some adversity
but you want to see what this young man
can do in the face of adversity
when he faces um the the new orleans
saints which is one of the best defenses
not the best defense in the league mike
florio
yeah good news jalen hurts you're
playing this weekend bad news you're
facing the new orleans saints and
my concern for carson wentz is this
notion that
to the extent that jay glaser's report
from over the weekend is accurate i have
no reason to doubt it that carson
wentz's confidence was shaken by the
drafting of jalen hurts
it becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy if
wence really was rattled by this so now
we see what hertz can do
and if hertz can't get it done maybe
wentz feels a little bit better if wence
gets back on the field at some point but
it felt like it had gotten to the point
where
it was unsustainable on the current path
the eagles had to do something rodney
it's a great point the players talk
the in the locker room they know who the
players are that should be on the field
and they're at the point where
they need to see what hurts can do
because wence wasn't getting it done
but my question to you two guys would be
how then do you ever go back to carson
wentz if you're the philadelphia eagles
how do you go back to him if
coach that's the thing i mean if you're
a professional athlete this is part of
it sometimes you're going to play well
sometimes you're going to struggle
and if you happen to get benched then
you have to pick yourself up and you
have to be ready for your team
so a lot of times when you guys and i've
heard you say this for over a decade
that you can't go back that you can't
why not why can't you go back that's
your job as a player
whether you're starting or whether
you're a backup you have to be
be prepared to play football whenever
the coach calls on you
and my point comes with this caveat you
could go back to carson wentz if jalen
hurts completely and totally fails
but i think for 2021 then you have a
real problem and the eagles have a huge
problem they have 25 million already
fully guaranteed
for carson wentz next season it dawned
on me yesterday maybe they could try to
trade him to the colts and reunite him
with frank reich who was the offensive
coordinator
in philadelphia the year that wentz
looked like he was going to be the mvp
but that's about it and if reich isn't
interested in wentz then no one else
should be because reich makes the most
sense with philip rivers on a one-year
contract
but i think for next year what this
tells us coach
like you're saying they've given up on
carson wentz maybe he gets a chance late
in the year to do something
but come next year it feels like there's
going to be a different quarterback in
philadelphia
hey coach
show me an example where it's worked
where you've taken a quarterback out a
franchise guy
you've benched him and then come back to
him and he's done the job for you i
maybe there are some examples i can't
think of one off the top of my head
let me ask you this coach what level of
responsibility is it to the coach
because if
if a coach is if a coach is trying to
hold everyone accountable
that has to include the quarterback i
know it's not the same as everyone else
because he's such a special unique
position
but coach flat out you cannot tell me
that jalen hurts doesn't deserve at
least an opportunity to see what he has
they drafted him in the second round you
know i agree that you have to hold
everybody accountable
i'm just saying that when you do it with
the quarterback
you've made a public statement that yes
i think at this moment jalen hurts is
better than carson wentz
that's what doug peterson is saying now
when you say that
it then becomes hard to put carson wentz
back in that's all i'm saying i think
they made a
statement for december of 2020 i think
they made a statement going forward hey
coach i got one for you
i got one for you i had to go way back i
had to go way back
but your original nfl mentor going into
the 1974 season
bench terry bradshaw for joe gillum yeah
and that year worked out with terry
bradshaw holding the trophy not that he
did anything to win it that year but he
would later become a franchise
quarterback so that's the only one i
could think of
but at least it has happened it did and
i will say those were special
circumstances
if you remember that was a strike here
bradshaw didn't come into camp
joe gillum did and started the season
that way and then he went to bradshaw
but
you're right that would be an example
and what is that 45 years ago
yeah it doesn't happen
right so guys what i would say is this
if
hold on liam if i'm one of those guys in
that locker room there's no way i'm
sitting back on the sideline if i'm
if i'm fletcher cox or one of those guys
and i'm looking at that crap that carson
wentz is putting out there
time and time again see i played on a
one in 15 team i played when
we had the number one defense in the
league and we had the worst offense in
the league
and even every day we would go out there
practice hard we would go out there and
play
and time and time again it was an
interception it was a sack it was a
strip sack for a touchdown
and we got so frustrated and so bitter
at the offense that we wouldn't even
talk to the offense
and those are the type of things that
you're going to be up against
if you continue to allow carson wentz to
go out there and sting up the place
that's all i'm saying
but but part of it is is not all carson
wins part of those strip sacks are
bad offensive line play receivers not
getting open receivers dropping the ball
no running game
yeah carson wentz is the quarterback but
a lot of that bad
offense is not just carson wentz now
we'll find out
if jalen hurts may give him a spark
we'll see
yeah and if it doesn't work with hertz i
mean in a way you ratchet up the
pressure again
on peterson and you look at how the
eagles close out right the saints the
cardinals the cowboys in washington
all right so let's say they beat the
cowboys four win team
are we looking at a team potentially
mike floria that's not only moves on for
the face of its franchise
with the quarterback but doug peterson
could be on the hot seat and they could
be looking for a new coach
i don't know that doug peterson would be
on the hot seat this year i think next
year he would be there was some
speculation
earlier this week and he was actually
asked about whether or not he wants
out of philadelphia he he said that he
doesn't i don't expect him to say
anything other than that but there is a
strange vibe right now and there are
questions about the dynamics
between the front office and the
coaching staff is the front office
acquiring people that the coaching staff
really wants and
it's stunning if any of this is true
because this is the team that just won
the super bowl three years ago
and then they were almost back in the
nfc championship game the next year and
then they got to the playoffs last year
and but for genevieve and clownies hit
on carson wentz early in the game
maybe they would have beaten the
seahawks that day so it's amazing how
quickly the eagles have fallen apart
i think going into next year though
everybody's on the hot seat
especially if they can't find someone to
take carson wentz off their hands
all right well they played the saints
this weekend i'll finish with this
rodney i'm just curious going forward if
money was no object
and you were starting a franchise who
would you rather have as your
quarterback carson wentz or taysom hill
um well it depends on who my head coach
is if my head coaches sean payton i'm
taking taysom hill
fair enough fair enough all right so
it's eagle saints this weekend
let's talk about that other team in uh
the state of pennsylvania because there
are no more undefeated teams in the nfl
the steelers they lost to the football
team now we'll see them sunday night
in buffalo against the bills mike tomlin
handling this very
philosophically i want to read you a
quote from him different points along
the journey get a chance to learn about
yourself
what you're made of individually and
collectively takes a journey to reveal
that we
faced a loss now we get the opportunity
to
smile in the face of this so rodney you
mentioned some of the bad times when
you're on a
one-win team and the defense and offense
weren't getting along but you're also on
teams that
flirted with perfection and the pressure
of that
is a loss here in the long run a good
thing for the steelers
i think so i mean i think it's a burden
it's off the players back i think
uh the the coaches carry a tremendous um
burden it's just a lot of pressure
you know every time you look up people
are asking you questions and the media
they're in your face now that you lost
you don't have to worry about answering
those questions now you can say you know
what and a lot of times too coach i was
thinking it is
when you have an undefeated season and
you've been there you have a lot of
issues that's going on
on your team but because you're
undefeated you have such a great record
everyone thinks that you're
that you're a perfect team and that's
just not the case for distillers
i i totally agree with you rodney we
were in that position
twice i think we were 13-0 one year with
indy and i was 9-0
and everybody's are you shooting for the
and you try to tell them no
we aren't shooting for a perfect season
that would be great if we get it
we're shooting to be perfect in the
playoffs and win the super bowl that's
the goal
and you're right this team had a lot of
issues
even when they're winning games they
were struggling in the red zone they're
struggling running the ball
defensive breakdowns they've got people
injured so those are the things that
mike tomlin has to fix and i think
that's why he was so philosophical about
it
hey we're not going to be undefeated not
the way we're playing we've got to get
some of these issues fixed and it better
start quick or they'll have another
defeat
sunday in buffalo last wednesday night
when they beat the ravens 19 to 14 and
there was a late touchdown that made
that game closer than it was
mike tomlin's post game press conference
was four minutes of him being
extremely upset i mean it was epic how
upset he was
to be the head coach of an 11-0 team
this week and
and and i couldn't wait for it after
they blow a 14-point lead
lose to washington it's going to be even
better than last week
he seemed relieved he seemed happy
he seemed relaxed that burden was gone
of being undefeated and now
rodney to your point he could go back to
the players and say the stuff you guys
are doing
needs to change this loss proves that we
need to do x y and z and one of the
things they need to do is find their
running game how can you have a
pittsburgh steelers team
that is a playoff contender that has no
running game and i think this will be
especially with james connor coming off
the coveted reserve list
an opportunity to re-embrace the running
game in pittsburgh
guys and i'll tell you this just
watching the game and not having bud
dupree out there
that's a huge loss like this guy was
having such a tremendous year
and then not just him individually but
the energy that everyone fed off of
especially tj watt those guys are like
best friends
high-fiving doing their dance and
basically competing
to see who can meet at the quarterback
first so i think this is a huge loss i
know mike tomlin mike you talked about
him being frustrated a couple weeks ago
and i think a big part of that
was the fact that he lost bud dupree
such a premium pass rusher and an impact
player for their team
i think you're right rodney he he knew
what that was going to do
already having lost devin bush
and now you take another weapon out of
that front seven
they're not the same on defense they've
got to get that figured out mike florio
talked about the running game
how about seven drop passes can we get
some receivers that can just catch the
ball when it comes to you
those are the things that they've got to
get ironed out right now they are
a possession passing team and when you
you don't run it and you're throwing
possession passes and your receivers
drop the ball
it's hard to move it well let me say
this disappoint chris sims has been
making
because they're doing that that short
passing game that is equivalent to the
running game
the defensive players know it's coming
those guys are getting hit
no excuse for dropping the passes but
those receivers are getting hit
a lot harder than they'd be getting hit
if they were throwing the ball down the
field
well it's a lot to figure out for a team
that's going to play three games in 12
games and i finished it all
finishes off sunday night against a
buffalo bills team that
looked excellent the other night they're
gonna have to figure out josh allen
so now we have a new top team in the afc
and it's meet the old ball same as
meet the new ball same as the old balls
right the super bowl champion kansas
city chiefs
they're on top of the afc they're going
to be taking on the 8-4 dolphins
okay brian flores you'd have to say in
the mix right now for coach of the year
so tony what do you think he has planned
what do you think he has in store
to try to slow down this casey offense
and what does he take away from what
denver did
well denver did some creative things
kansas city was a little off and and i
don't think
they had their a game you can't go into
kansas city or play the chiefs thinking
and we're going to slow them down we're
going to hold patrick mahomes at 17
points
you've got to score points brian flores
will have a good plan
maybe they hold them to 24 maybe they
hold them to 27.
that'll be a great game for the dolphins
tuatanga vailoa and that group
they're going to have to score points so
if i'm brian flores that's what i'm
figuring out kansas city's weakness is
their defense right now they haven't
played a great defensive
game in a long while you've got to
figure out a way to score points
miami and coach everything that brian
flores did in this offseason was about
not beating the patriots or even winning
afc east but it was about competing with
the kansas city chiefs go out and get
pass rushers
veterans smart linebackers a good
secondary
and i'm with you coach they're going to
have to score points and when i look at
tua
first i look at two and i love this kid
he looks so
frail when he's he just looks so small
and so
tiny when when you kind of look at him
so every time he drops back to pass if
somebody hit someone like oh i'm just
cringing is he gonna get hurt but
but yeah they're gonna have to um
they're gonna have to definitely be able
to run the football and that's one of
the biggest things it's not just
playing defense creating turtles but
they're gonna have to take some pressure
off the tour
and be able to run the football mike
flores said on wednesday morning he
wishes he could have 14
guys on defense after watching the
chiefs on film but remember this
porres was the de facto defensive
coordinator in new england
when the patriots went to kansas city
and beat the chiefs in the afc
championship game and they came up with
the plan flores and coach bill belichick
together
to single cover the receivers and then
have a safety over the top who always
went toward tyreek hill and
always favored helping out and
protecting against tyreek hill busting
the thing wide open and i expect them to
do something like that and
you know we've seen what happens with
the chiefs when it's not a marquee game
and they've got the saints next weekend
they
tend to be a little flat they tend to
sleepwalk they still
typically find a way to win but i just
wonder even though the dolphins are 8-4
is this going to be the kind of team
that gets the full focus and attention
of the chiefs
and mike those scores against the the
patriots
even though the patriots were winning
the game what were the scores
they were in the 30s and they were going
into overtime so
yes did brian flores had part of some
good plans to stop
patrick mahomes but they had tom brady
and they scored a bunch of points to win
those games
but guys even if you look at the game
earlier this year the patriots did a
good job of
and it really confused patrick mahomes
kind of early in the game they rushed
three
they dropped eight they had eight guys
kind of clogging up those lanes and when
patrick mahomes dropped back he was kind
of like confused
and i think that might be something that
brian flores do he forces him to go to
long hard way 10 to 12 play drives don't
give up anything deep
and just stay patient if they can stay
patient patrick mahomes is a great
talent but he has so much confidence
he will throw it up and give you an
opportunity to go up for it liam so
i expect brian flores to show those two
linebackers seven guys up blitz
just show him uh just a variety of
defenses
yeah you know the dolphins are going to
be ready but you know more to mike's
point
this kansas city team that has what one
loss in the last 14 months
the panthers they beat them by two they
beat the raiders by four in a last
minute drive on our sunday night game
they beat the bucks by three they were
up big in that game didn't put that game
away they beat the broncos 22
to 16. tony i know we're nitpicking
because that's really all you can do
with kansas city at this point is is
nitpick but
does it bother you at all that this is a
supposed great team that
beats teams but doesn't just push aside
and push their weight through or tear
their way through some of these teams
well i don't think they're going to be
able to do that until their defense
starts playing at a high level and we
said this all of last year i didn't
think they were a super bowl team
because i didn't think they could stop
people
in the playoffs that defense ramped it
up i think they get bored
especially on offense defensively i
think they take a lot of chances
if you have a great offense you can take
advantage of some of those
they can play uh games like they played
against tampa where in the first half
they stopped tom brady
shut them down but second half with the
same defenses some of those balls now
become completions and they give up 24
points and a half
so i think that's what they are on
defense but on offense
it's just a matter of how they attack
the game
uh denver yeah 22 points tyree
hill caught a ball in the end zone that
was a touchdown pass
true um ran had another long pass that
got called back for a holding penalty
two touchdowns they should have had
uh it's got stopped on the one-yard line
so they were
that close to 40 points in that game and
that's how that offense is
a bad day you hold them down to 24.
if they have a good day they're going to
score 40. that's what you're dealing
with
guys you know what i like when you're
facing when you're trying to go back to
back
the second the second time it's tough a
lot of times because
you don't really always get up for every
single game
and so when i look at kansas city i've
been in that situation before so i don't
look at them as like oh they have to
blow everyone out to impress me
the fact that they're winning games in
different ways i just think that it
builds character
and it builds trust amongst amongst
their players and their coaching staff
um if if i would have to say anything
critic
any criticism toward their offense is
like you coach
they get a little goofy with some of
their plays they get bored they try some
silly things
on the goal line and i think that's part
of the reason why they've had some
struggles in the red zone
all right so their team right now go
ahead john
i was gonna say they've lost one game in
a year and a half and that was 40 to 32.
so we can be critical but
yeah and also let's face it
and we're nitpicking because you have to
because there's no other way to
go at them and it's a team that you
could say maybe wasn't that focused in a
couple of games in the playoffs
and then stormed back in those games and
won those games went to the super bowl
and then won that game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
games coming up this weekend involving
bubble teams let's start with the colts
raiders this one is from vegas
indianapolis the last team in
vegas first team out and rodney i'll
start with you you look at this matchup
how do you see this playing out
i just look at the colts man and just
watching their defense they are totally
different defense when they have the big
guy to force buckner in the lineup if
they can keep him
healthy they rely on his physical
presence his leadership and everything
they have to keep him healthy coach
i i agree with you it's going to be the
colts run defense can josh jacobs get
the running game
going for the raiders if he does then i
think they have a good shot to win it if
the raiders don't run for 140 150 yards
it's going to be tough on them the
raiders defense is not great
i would see frank wright pounding the
ball at them a little bit and then
trying to go after the big play so i
think it's all going to be on the
raiders running game
and uh that deforest buckner-led front
seven for for indianapolis
you know the cardinals haven't won a
game since the hail murray from a few
weeks back and i feel like the raiders
could
step into that same problem they won a
game they had no business winning
against a winless team they know that
that was a gift and they have to have
their confidence ultimately shaken
by getting blown out in atlanta being on
the verge of losing to the jets
and now comes a playoff team with
deforest buckner back which makes a huge
difference
i i think that that this is the one
where the colts move toward
the field of seven and the raiders get
closer to accepting the fact that maybe
next year
they got an absolute gift last week
we'll see if it carries over four of
them or if it's negative the way it was
for
arizona when they won on that hail
murray play we finish up with your
vikings mike florio
and the bucks last two teams currently
in that
nfc playoff picture cardinals right
behind them there okay you know the
story minnesota right one and five and
now
five and one cents so they're six and
six tampa bay has lost
three of four coming off the buy
what do you expect in this one mike
floria
well i i remember back in 1990 the
vikings started one and six they won
five in a row to get to six and six and
everything was pointing in a great
direction and here they go
and then they lost the next four
including a game of the buccaneers along
the way so
i i don't i don't have a whole lot of
faith especially because number one the
vikings have never beaten tom brady
number two the vikings don't have the
pass rush especially up the middle to
get to tom brady
on the back end they don't have the
secondary to deal with mike evans chris
godwin antonio brown
and rob gronkowski and if michael
kendricks
isn't or eric kendrick's excuse me isn't
able to play after the pregame
warm-up calf aggravation from last week
that makes it even harder and i don't
know the vikings can run the ball the
way they need to
against the tampa bay defense and the
buccaneers had two weeks to get ready so
i expect that after this game the
buccaneers will be eight and five and
the vikings will be done
and we can all move on and focus on the
teams that really are the contenders in
the nfc team's one five of six and the
sky is falling from mike florio
liam liam liam mike florio why are you
so negative
about the vikings it just came up a huge
win
over the jaguars that's a huge win it's
barely beating the jaguars
bear and coming from from double digits
behind they did it two weeks in a row
against teams they should have blown out
to the panthers
and the jaguars down double digits and
they had to come back and win those
games and
uh you know they have not had a great
win this year other than the win
at lambeau field i i just think that
it's a lot of smoke and mirrors lately
and we're gonna we're gonna see that
when they face the buccaneers coach
settle this one break the tie let me ask
you two guys this question okay this is
going to be a mirror image game
both defenses are going to load up
they're going to come with all kinds of
blitzes that's the way they play that's
their style
can which quarterback is going to hit
his receivers
in the face of that that pressure who do
you have more confidence in
kirk cousins and justin jefferson and
adam thielen
or tom brady and mike evans and chris
godwin
there was a time we wouldn't even ask
that question but i'll tell you what
down here in tampa
that's the question that's being asked
can tom brady deliver
when he's going to be under pressure and
is he going to be able to outgun
kirk cousins what do you guys think i i
don't know coach but
i tell you this if i'm kirk cousins i
got a lot of confidence going into this
game because i'm looking at those
secondary guys i'm looking at those
corners in particular carlton davis
anytime i see justin jefferson or adam
thielen on him
101 i'm going after him i'm trying to
take his confidence i'm trying to take
every kind
sense of confidence that he has so if
i'm kirk cousins i feel pretty good
about
um going against this defense i tell my
line just give me a few seconds we can
work these cornerbacks and remember
when tampa bay if they decide to play
more zone
the rams and jared goff absolutely just
tore him apart in that zone so i i
expect kirk cousins to play extremely
well he's going to compete against tom
brady because
if they lose this game then the the
minnesota vikings
their playoff hopes are done and i'm
curious to see what the buccaneers do on
offense
yeah i'm curious what's that
i said that's the talk in the barbershop
they're concerned that kirk cousins is
going to
outgun tom brady in this game so we'll
see this has been like a third
question for mike florian
it hasn't made me feel any better
therapy's supposed to make you feel
better
and you know what liam ignored liam you
know what liam
i trust that mike zimmer he's been in
different situations he hasn't always
had he still got two really good
safeties back there
and i just think that he's gonna come up
with a game plan and like
he's not afraid of tom brady like if i'm
playing against tom brady right now i
wouldn't be afraid of tom brady
especially with all the numbers because
i know
that they're not on the same page but
coach you and i we've talked about this
for years
pressure them up the middle make them
feel uncomfortable
jam up the receiver slow him down and
you can have success against these guys
and zimmer is an excellent defensive
coordinator he's going to make those
necessary adjustments
okay listening to it
the best hope the vikings have is if the
buccaneers continue to not be on the
same page about how they're going to run
their offense so they're going to try to
spread the receivers out
throw the ball down the field or are
they going to try to establish the run
use multiple tight ends
and soften up the vikings that way
before hitting them with play action
and we've seen this every week we don't
know what they want to be offensively
and if they haven't resolved that during
the bye week then they have a problem
yeah you can't resolve it during the bye
week until you actually get on the
football
field and start doing it because a lot
of things happen you know
what if their game plan is to go to mike
evans but yet the defense
then tom brady has to decide to do
something different so
you know until bruce arians gets back to
doing what tom is very comfortable with
running a football and two tight end
sets play action pass
a couple trick plays here and there
spread them out getting rid of the ball
quickly tom's not going to be
comfortable and tom's going to continue
to throw interceptions
you know i'm curious about that rodney
that last point
do you don't you think at this point
that tom brady is essentially making
those calls
be it at the line of scrimmage or in
conversations
over zoom or in conversations on the
sideline don't you think that offense
is at this point going to be determined
by what tom brady wants
that's what i that's what i've been
saying but you have to understand you're
dealing with bruce arians and he has an
ego and coaches have egos and say
this is the way i visualize my offense
working i want it to be big plays down
the field we got
two pro bowl three pro bowl wide
receivers tight ends everywhere
so i want to be explosive he doesn't
want a dinkin dunk
bruce aaron is not patient enough for a
four-yard game three-yard game he's like
why the heck did i bring this guy in if
he's just gonna throw four
or five yards passes he wants to be
explosive down the field coach
i i agree with you rodney we've watched
this offense for 12 13 weeks now
this is not the offense that we've seen
tom brady flourish in
uh tom's trying to make adjustments
bruce is trying to adjust for tom
it just hasn't hit in sync yet tom brady
is
quick rhythm throw the ball know where
it's going get rid of it
fast be accurate and we haven't seen
that this year
well we'll see what happens here mike
florio is going to remain quiet because
at this point we
were kind of overdoing it i feel like as
a vikings fan over there in the corner
that's
awesome
completely unconvinced i've seen this
movie many times
over the last 50 years yeah you know the
ending well we'll see what happens it's
vikings at bucks that's a big one coming
up and of course our sunday night game
is an excellent one in the afc we get
the buffalo bills hosting the pittsburgh
steelers and i'll see you guys there
sunday nights
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports